Imagine someone coming into your kitchen and taking a few tools,
a pan and your garbage, then they bury everything in the woods.
12,000 years later, an archeologist is trying to figure out who you were,
what was important to you, what video games you played,
what you believed in and what informed your decisions because you happened to
live during a remarkable time in human history.
The Planetree revolution,
when the humanity transitioned becoming a multi-planetary species
in that time, our numbers would explode by orders of magnitude.
Our technology and standard of living would improve to levels.
Previously thought impossible, and our self-conception would change forever.
And all the future archeologists has to learn about is your junk in the woods.
While we can only hope that this will be someone's problem. In 12,000 years,
we have the same problem today.
We're trying to reconstruct a revolution that took place 12,000 years ago.
Today only shadows remain of the people who experienced our distant
past as they're present,
what remains from our past.
We can look at our present in crispy 4k,
in color and sound three generations ago,
the world was just black and white, one more generation.
And we see the world through blurred photographs,
further back paintings and texts become our main way of experiencing the
past Amir 20 generations before us today,
every written word had to be copied by hand and reports became more scarce and
less reliable.
The first historian lived Amir 100 generations ago before
him.
There are only epics and legends and dead Kings bracking on pieces of
stone, 250 generations ago.
There are only fragments left in the ground and images stripped to their
original meaning.
Eventually humanity becomes basically invisible. Still.
We do know some things about our ancestors.
Let's try to tell their story and what it means for us today.
The greatest transition in human history for some 2 million
years or roughly 80,000 generations,
the life of our ancestors was basically the same.
It was around 20,000 years or 800 generations ago that the behaviorally
modern humans began a process that would change our lifestyle forever.
At first, gradually for some of us then faster for more of us,
and then suddenly for almost all of us back then there were
about 1 million modern humans on earth.
Most other human species had died out probably with a little help from us.
Our ancestors biology had given them the necessary tools,
a general intelligence to understand things as social intelligence,
to understand each other and language,
to express abstract ideas and create new concepts.
These were people just like you.
They suffered and experienced joy were bored, cried, and laughed.
They lived in communities of a few dozen people.
They controlled fire and had tools made from wood stone and bone
told stories, born bad dad and created art.
They traded with other tribes from obsidian to shellfish,
some hunted big game and were very mobile. Others relied more on plants.
They collected and others mostly stayed in one area with an abundance of
seafood.
This was the common state of humanity for most of our history until a slow
transition. Step-by-step turned into a revolution
step by step.
The first solid evidence for this stems from the Jordan Valley,
where our ancestors collected wild wheat, more than 20,000 years ago,
they noticed that seeds in the ground made more plants the next year.
If they put good ones in one place the next year,
they had more of the good ones.
This was a great supplement to hunting and gathering.
You could prepare some crops return next year,
build a temporary settlement and have a secure food supply.
Our ancestors used these bonus trumps to bake the first bread and brew the first
beer with every generation.
They gathered deeper knowledge about the plants and animals around them and how
to manipulate them to their advantage.
But there was a lot to learn very slowly from generation to generation
pockets of knowledge expanded and were passed along to be expanded. Again,
this early agriculture started to drastically reduce the space.
Our ancestors needed to feed one individual,
which made it possible to stay in one place longer around 12,000 years
ago, these little pieces of progress had reached a critical mass.
Most of the calories we consume today STEM from about 15 different founder crops
that humans began to domesticate in earnest in the next few thousand years,
what we call the agricultural revolution was not a thing that began suddenly.
One day it was a slow process driven by small groups over many
generations.
Eventually gradual change gave rise to a new era.
This human error during the next few thousand years,
progress would speed up and turn Hunter gatherers into farmers who lived in
villages, towns, and then cities. When farmers moved into new areas,
they replaced the nomadic tribes or turn them into farmers too.
This was neither easy nor painless. In the early days,
people had a diverse diet made up of up to 250 different plants and animals
for some of the transitioning to agriculture,
the variation in their diets declined drastically and some even seem to have
been under nourished and living close together.
And with animals created a breeding ground for disease.
Virtually every infectious disease caused by micro organisms that have adapted
to humans arose in the last 10,000 years, cholera smallpox,
measles, influenza chicken box and malaria mortality,
especially among children, Rose drastically,
still loud numbers grew because living in the same place enabled women to bear
far more children than before. And for a farmer,
more kids mean more hands to work. The fields,
even with more people dying,
younger villages and towns grew the number of humans earth
exploded about 100 generations.
After the beginning of the human era, there were already 4 million of us.
This increased the need for food and people to come up with evermore efficient
ways of producing canneries, solidifying our new life style,
going back to hunting and gathering would have just meant death by starvation.
For most one question remains unanswered. Why,
why would we'll exchange the freedom of living off nature with a huge variety in
food for the grind of agriculture and often more limited diets?
Nobody knows for sure.
Climate change seems to have made the transition possible.
And some scientists argue that it was caused by external factors like under
nourishment or overpopulation,
both highly contested today.
The most widely accepted idea is that it was a deliberate choice made by
countless communities around the globe.
Maybe it's also connected with what makes us human,
the ability to come together,
develop shared identities and exchange stories and knowledge.
Some archeologists think that groups of hunter-gatherers traveled long and far
to celebrate to hold feasts and rituals.
They would have used these occasions to talk about their version of innovation,
better hunting and toolmaking techniques how to catch and read animals and which
plants could be collected and multiplied. Maybe they even exchanged seeds.
It's not unlikely that these gatherings were the catalyst that spread the
knowledge of agriculture through the many isolated groups of humanity,
ultimately ending a lifestyle that was common to our species for thousands of
generations. So by being able to come together, celebrate, share,
and learn from one another.
These humans might've taken the steps that led to our modern world.
And we have much to be grateful for.
We are still the same humans today, even if it often doesn't feel that way,
maybe it's time to come together to share what we know and celebrate our
existence. Once again, to begin another peaceful transition,
maybe the planetary revolution that will change once more.
So hopefully in another 12,000 years,
our descendants will look back on us today with gratitude,
for the amazing world. They are able to inhabit
to celebrate the achievements of our ancestors in the last 12,000 years.
And to look with hope towards the next 12,000.
We present you with the fifth human error calendar for the year 12,021.
This time.
It's all about the journey of humanity.
Beginning tens of thousands of years ago,
leading into the revolution of agriculture to ancient high civilizations
and the beginning of modern times culminating in a vision for our future.
You can get the limited edition now until we set out and then never again,
as always the calendar features 12 illustrated pages printed on high quality
paper in Europe and the U S and this year, the cover is especially shiny.
Not only does the calendar look great on walls and makes it easier to dream
about a glorious future and realize how far we've come as a species.
It's also the best way to support cods Cozart.
The calendar enables us to put in the timeout videos need and release them for
free for everyone. If you want,
you can get the Canada with a hoodie or infographic posters or plushy.
We've met a few deals for you.
Thank you so much to the thousands of people who get the calendar every year and
to the burbs who love what we try to do on this channel.
We wish you a happy year, 12,021,
and let's all hope that it will be less exciting than 12,020.